welcome back
today we're talking with dr simon
kornblith
a research scientist in the google brain
team simon is most famous for being one
of the authors on
simclear the computer vision paper that
used self-supervised learning and the
contrastive loss
with loads of cool image augmentations
simon
also used to be a neuroscientist when i
was pretty young
i was interested in consciousness and
how we
create this kind of impression of the
external world inside our heads
and so i guess it's pretty obvious how
that translates into an interest in
brains and how the brain works
turns out the neuroscience is really
difficult progress is really slow
and tedious simon's goal is to
understand
the inner workings of neural networks
both in meat space
and in silicon he initially thought that
the artificial
variety might be easier to understand
he was in for a rude awakening so in a
neural network we can record all the
neurons which is
extremely challenging in a biological
organism
and we can also manipulate the system in
any
kind of way that we can imagine but it
still seems really hard to understand
neural networks i think there are a lot
of ideas from machine learning
that will ultimately help us understand
brains
maybe we could make some headway that
might eventually translate back to
brains
and so that's how i ended up in machine
learning people often try and
anthropomorphize
neural networks people try to relate
whatever
neural network they've built back to a
brain and they say that it works like
the brain but it doesn't work like the
brain so simon was involved in this
paper do wide and deep networks learn
the same things
uncovering how neural network
representations vary with width and
depth
simon pioneered this really fascinating
way of comparing
representations by comparing features
and what this essentially amounts to
is we need to have a similarity function
so that we can compare
the representations in layers to
themselves in different parts of the
network or indeed to other networks
so for this similarity measure to work
well the first thing simon did was take
two
architecturally identical networks a and
b
drain from different random
initializations and just ensure that the
the third convolution layer is more
self-similar to
its counterpart than any of the other
layers
if that works then you're on to
something turns out that's not super
simple to do but simon came up with this
concept called the centered kernel
alignment which we'll talk about on the
call
but this is actually super fascinating
we're talking about this idea here
of using self-similarity to reason
about the evolution of representations
throughout successive layers in the
neural network and what simon found
is that you get this kind of
characteristic blockiness
so when you see these large blocks what
it means is that the representations are
no longer evolving in respect of time
so it's showing here the
representational similarity
of all of the layers against themselves
and against all of the other layers
so clearly there's this characteristic
diagonal down the matrix as you would
see with any self-similarity matrix
and because this blockiness appears it
means that
nothing is happening and what simon
realized is you can actually delete
these layers from the neural network and
it wouldn't make any difference because
it hasn't learned anything new but it's
also a really interesting way of
reasoning about
a kind of pathology a weird thing that
happens when you saturate a neural
network
so you said that this presence of this
block structure is an indicator of the
halting of evolution
and a strong indicator of over
parameterization
and he actually shows that this
blockiness appears on deeper networks
and wider networks
but this concept of similarity analysis
is not new to me
on my phd i was fascinated in segmenting
dj mixed music shows and i actually used
the same techniques for
learning regimes in financial data sets
later on but
this is an example of a dj mix which i
segmented i came up with a
dynamic programming algorithm which
would essentially
sum up all of the tiles along this
diagonal and compute the lowest cost
contiguous segmentation and it's super
interesting so here are two music tracks
and you can see
that they are more self-similar to each
other than they are any of the other
tracks
just because of the tone of the color
here and if you zoom into a track you
can even see that there are symmetries
this part of the track here is a
repetition from
this part of the track here and you can
tell that from
this kind of symmetry pattern on the
diagonal
and you can see that there's a little
bit in the track in the middle here
which is not
similar to any other part of the track
you see some really interesting stuff
here and
you know essentially i'm a huge fan of
anyone using self-similarity matrices
for
reasoning about the evolution of
representations i think it's a
fascinating idea
so how did simon come up with this
measure of similarity the
centered kernel alignment jeff hinton
had another idea
and i tried the idea that it worked but
then we wondered
is there a simpler thing that worked and
that's how we ended up with centered
kernel alignment
the blockiness in these matrices is
absolutely fascinating
but how much can we read into it it's
not clear what we should really expect
in terms of how a neural network
representation
evolves through the layers i think
there's kind of some theory on what we
should expect
if all the layers are linear but like
obviously
the neural networks that we train are
non-linear and it's really important to
have a non-linearity in between the
layers
if we see that nothing is changing from
one layer to the next
that's a really bad sign if the neural
network representation isn't changing
then obviously nothing's happening
we couldn't have predicted this ahead of
time based on what we know about
neural network theory and we couldn't
have predicted it ahead of time
based on the accuracy of the network
does this apply to resnets though
i thought that they could learn their
own capacity you can either
look at networks without residual
connections where you do actually find
that at some depth
the accuracy will start going down and
and in in networks without residual
connections we find that like
that the depth where accuracy starts to
go down is like around the same depth
where you begin seeing this kind of
block structure where
many successive layers have similar
representations and it looks like the
representation is no longer getting
refined through the network
once you start getting these blocks
making the network deeper
making that work wider no longer really
gives you
any improvement in accuracy so it seems
like this is basically telling you that
the network has
fit the data as much as it can and
there's no
real advantage to using something bigger
next we move on to simon's paper about
using different loss functions
on image classifiers and he made some
really interesting findings actually so
the loss functions only really seem to
affect
the penultimate layers in the neural
network
this also gives us some pretty useful
insight into transfer learning
the the last third of the network is
setting up the penultimate layer
representation
in a way that is good for your loss
function but
the first two thirds of the network are
somehow just learning
general features i think this also
corresponds with the
success of transfer learning where we
can take features that we've learned on
one task and transfer them to some other
tasks
what's the implication though it seems
is the implication that the loss
function is not having any impact
on the representations early on in the
network that seems like quite a big
implication
ultimately we're asking the network to
do the same thing just in a slightly
different way
there seems to be like some inverse
correlation between
the gains you get from a loss function
and how good it is for transfer learning
if you use loss functions that
give you higher accuracy on imagenet you
tend to learn
representations that transfer
substantially worse
in that setting the loss functions that
perform better
lead classes to become more separated in
the penultimate layers if you just use
standard softmax loss
actually the classes are not that
separated from each other in the
penultimate layer representation
right now on whatever tensorflow hub or
hogging face repositories and so on we
have these pre-trained models
and the pre-trend models they're like
full stack models and people usually
take some sort of
last or next to last hidden layer
but maybe we should much more focus on
actually providing like half of a
network to share
like determining which are actually the
best good
or general representations from a data
set and so on
it's a really interesting question if we
just want to turn an image into a vector
that we could then train a linear
classifier on top of
what is the best way of doing that
self-supervised pre-training just like
word vectors
gives us a really great starting point
to vectorize an image
into a semantically relevant geometric
space
it's been a real game changer in the
computer vision world since about 2018.
we want that neural network to learn a
representation
such that when we then just train a
linear classifier on top of that
representation
to classify imagenet it's going to do
well but we want to learn the initial
representation
without using any kind of labels so what
is self-supervised pre-training for
vision
people came up with these kinds of tasks
that you could try to train a neural
network to do
so that it would learn some kind of good
representation you're trying to
learn some kind of representation space
where you've got
different patches from an image or
different augmentations from an image
just different representations of the
same image
and you want to learn a representation
space where these representations of the
same image
are all close together in that
representation space
and they're far apart from the
representations of other images
this surprisingly seems to lead to very
good representations
i was very fascinated by all of these
different tricks that you
apparently have to get and so big kudos
to you know
figuring all of this out for the rest of
us
data augmentation is absolutely key to
making this work
important part of the recipe is data
augmentation
there are really only two super
important
data augmentations that we need so we
have to take
two different crops from the same image
and then we have to do
some kind of color distortion turns out
though the architecture isn't that
important
you don't have to worry about
architecture engineering
specifically for contrastive learning
what was new in the sim clr paper we
introduced
uh the idea of this projection head in
simclear
and we also spend a lot of time studying
the augmentation
and what about the bring your own latent
paper i don't really have any insight
into
how either vyol or the more recent
papers actually are learning a
representation that doesn't end up
collapsing
why it doesn't happen relates to some
mysteries about neural network training
dynamics that we still don't entirely
understand
we dive deep into data augmentation in
general the data augmentation that you
need for contrastive learning
is different from the data augmentation
that you need for supervised learning
because the task is different
when you have contrastive learning you
have this problem that
if there's just one feature in your data
that can be used
to do the contrastive task to get images
of the same example or views of the same
example close together and far apart
from views of all the other examples if
you could do that with one feature
that would be the only feature the
network would ever learn or it might be
the only feature the network would ever
learn
and so with the augmentation you're
making the task harder so that the
network actually has to learn
many different kinds of features we find
that like
this color distortion actually is very
important
for self-supervised learning for
contrastive learning whereas it doesn't
really matter for supervised learning
there seems to be this fascinating
universality of
representations especially in vision i'm
not trying to be flippant when i say
this because
practitioners have used imagenet on a
variety of downstream
tasks for example they might use it for
classifying circuit boards or something
and the miraculous thing is it just
seems to work quite well so
do you think in your opinion that there
is some kind of universality
i'm very skeptical about like
universality of imagenet for different
tasks
even though there are lots of cars in
imagenet if you free train on imagenet
and you fine tune on that dataset
you will learn to classify it faster in
fewer steps than if you had trained
from scratch on the the stanford cars
dataset
but you won't actually perform any
better at the end representations of
images
are not that universal and at least what
works
for natural images like those in
imagenet
may not work on other data sets going a
bit from the
universality of representations
to the universality of augmentation
since this is
such a crucial part do you think that
there is
a systematic way how we can discover
augmentations right now it seems to be
kind of a whack-a-mole right
it's okay we just feed images it's no
that's too easy we crop them
oh no it's the color histogram so we
like whack on the color and then
it works better but maybe someone finds
out oh there is still this
easy feature that the network every now
and then
pays attention to so we design a method
to
whack on that a bit do you think there
is a systematic way
or will this kind of philosophically
always rely on us humans
having a higher level insight of what we
want to do
with the data set so what comes next
after data
augmentation so would the next step be
some simulation
do you know what i mean where we impute
physics and we impute some world
knowledge and then i don't know whether
we train a machine learning model from
that
yeah i think like there are definitely
shortcomings in
like our current machine learning models
understandings of the world
there they're probably things that we
can't just solve by throwing more static
images at them
i think like maybe the next step rather
than trying to
immediately situate the machine learning
model in a
kind of a simulated world we could just
think about video
i think like probably representation
learning from video is going to be
like a big thing next year or like the
year after
something sometime in the near future
finally we talk about simon's paper
big self-supervised models are strong
semi-supervised
learners what is a practical problem is
the situation where you have
a lot of unlabeled data and then a very
small amount of labeled data
what i find fascinating is how many
ideas come
together in this paper you you probably
didn't sit down
after a sim clear one and be like all
right what do we do for sinclair two
okay let's do this so there he tells me
there was this process could you if you
can maybe elaborate a bit on how did you
going to build up the system towards the
the final output we
we also tried the approach of first
fine-tuning the big network
and then distilling it and it turned out
that worked a lot
better and what we found was like this
approach of
pre-training then fine-tuning then
distilling works a lot better than
pre-training than distilling
then fine-tuning we probably shouldn't
expect
distillation of the the kind that we do
in sinclair v2 to work substantially
better than
like supervised distillation which has
been around for
quite a while now i i think what's
impressive is that in the
self-supervised case in the contrastive
case like
distillation basically allows you to
recover the same accuracy that you would
get from training supervised from
scratch whereas without it
like the accuracy is a lot worse so it
seems like it it maybe matters
more in this contrastive case but i
think
like generally when you do distillation
in the supervised case you can get like
maybe a percentage point gain
maybe a couple of percentage points and
i think that's probably about the limit
in terms of
the improvement that you could get from
any kind of distillation
based approach over supervised training
from scratch
can you use gans generative adversarial
neural networks
to do data augmentation or is that just
a myth
simon certainly seems to think so using
a gante to do data augmentation you have
this problem that
you still don't actually have more data
like you have a gan that's trained on
the same data
and so it might help you because like
your way of encoding inductive bias into
the gan
is different from your way of encoding
inductive bias
into the neural network and maybe like
by having more
inductive bias you can learn a better
function you still don't have more data
and it seems like
without having more data there's no
reason to expect a priority that you
will be able
to learn a better function ironically
when you do the simple data
augmentations you do have more data
because you have
you put all the knowledge in there as a
human of what makes two
images dissimilar visually but still
equivalent semantically which again
is exactly the opposite it gives you
images that are visually
similar but it has no intuition of
what the semantic similarity is we round
off the show by talking about simon's
love
of the julia language julia is a much
better
programming language than python in many
ways
julius designed for these situations
where maybe beyond just matrices
you have these funny types of structured
matrices you have sparse matrices and
you can define special methods for the
product of a sparse matrix and a vector
or
all sorts of things where you might want
different methods depending on the types
i really hope you've enjoyed the show
today we've had so much fun making it
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments every
single one of them and we'll see you
back
next week welcome back to the machine
learning street talk
youtube channel and podcast with my two
compadres syack the neural network
pruner pool
and yannick the light speed protein
folder
culture today we have an incredibly
special guest
simon cornblith and simon got his phd
in brain and cognitive sciences from mit
his undergrad was from caltech and he's
a research scientist at google brain
he's been there since about 2017. now
he's been cited
nearly 2 000 times which for someone
quite early in career is
seriously impressive he's got a keen
interest in the digital humanities
in philosophy computer science machine
learning
computer vision and neuroscience now he
used to be a neuroscientist before he
started doing machine learning and
he tells us that he's got some very
strong opinions about neuroscience and
machine learning which we
certainly will be getting on to later
he's a huge lover of the julia language
so if you google
simon's name you'll see him talking at
about a million julia
conferences so definitely check that out
as well
simon pioneered the use of centered
kernel alignment as a way of analyzing
the evolution of representations in
layers
in network and between networks of
different architectures
now simon like me is a lover of
similarity matrices
and what can be gleaned from them on my
own phd
i worked with them a lot for music
segmentation and also for detecting
regimes in financial data sets
when a block in a resnet is no longer so
similar to previous layers early on
you might intuit that it's moving into a
new representational regime
or maybe it's just started hallucinating
but all of this stuff was covered in his
paper do wide and deep neural networks
learn the same things
and i find it fascinating that
representational self-similarity
can reveal network pathology now in his
paper what's in a loss function for
image classification
he noted that different losses and
regularizers have similar accuracies on
several data sets
but using the same representational
evolution analysis
simon gleaned that these losses and
regularizers
only affected the penultimate layers in
the neural network revealing inherent
limitations in what can be achieved in
manipulating the loss
on a network now next in the session
today we're going to talk about the
simclear paper
and this was an incredibly exciting
paper for unsupervised contrastive image
learning with augmentations
it introduced a learnable non-linear
transformation between the
representations and the contrast of loss
which massively improved the
representations the composition of
augmentations is super important
and whenever anyone asks me about what
are the different data augmentations in
computer vision i always point them to
the sim clr paper because it's got this
wonderful matrix
and in that matrix it was shown that the
crop and the the color i think were the
most effective augmentations
but simon also noted that the batch
sizes were super important
and the paper improved over the state of
the art on the imagenet top one
and actually matched unsupervised
methods for the first time albeit with
many more parameters
but the final paper we're going to talk
about today is big self-supervised
models are strong
semi-supervised learners and this is
where you can learn from fewer labeled
examples while making use of
a large amount of unlabeled data and
with unsupervised
pre-training on simclr v2 supervised
fine-tuning on a few labeled examples
and then distillation with unlabeled
examples
this approach improved the label
efficiency over previous
state-of-the-art methods
i remember yannick lightspeed culture
made a video on this one which
i watched a few months ago so yannick
will have all of that completely fresh
in his mind
anyway simon it's an absolute pleasure
to welcome you to the show
thank you so much for coming it's great
to be here amazing how did you get into
machine learning
so i guess first i got into neuroscience
and then i got disillusioned with
neuroscience
when i was pretty young i was interested
in consciousness and how we create this
kind of impression of the external world
inside our heads
and so i guess it's pretty obvious how
that translates into an interest in
brains and how the brain works so
i spent both four years as an
undergraduate doing neuroscience
research
and then seven years working with
monkeys at mit
trying to figure out how monkey brains
work
and then after that i felt like we
weren't getting very far
by trying to record from neurons in
monkeys brains
and figure out how those neurons work so
i
i thought about what other ways are
there approaching this problem
how could we think about how to
understand
how the brain is doing tasks and it
seems like
maybe by building systems that can do
those tests
well that are not biological we could
learn more
so that's how i got into machine
learning i joined the google ai
residency program which is like this
great program that google has
to take people who have extensive
background
in some field that is not machine
learning and train them to do machine
learning
and i ended up at google and initially i
thought i'm going to spend like a year
here learning about machine learning
related stuff and then
maybe i'll go back to neuroscience and
i'll decide the the tools for machine
learning could be applied back to
brains and maybe we can learn more about
brains by applying
the tools of machine learning there but
ultimately i decided i was
more interested in just looking at how
the neural networks work
and and also like in the engineering
challenges of building better neural
networks
which i actually think are fun one of
the thoughts that came to my mind is
it's fascinating looking at the kind of
introspective analysis
that you've been conducting with neural
networks but could you contrast that
with
in neuroscience because as i understand
you have mri scans and you have
different ways of
trying to visualize and reason about the
behavior of a brain
but you can't really tweak the
architecture and tweak all of the knobs
and the levers in quite the same way you
do in
machine learning yeah so like in
neuroscience people also
use this analysis across different
individuals or different organisms or
whatever
it is a tool that people use in
neuroscience as well but i guess
they're limited in the ways in which
they could manipulate
the systems that are providing these
representations
so like in neuroscience you're like
always constrained by data
so you can compare representations of
images across
individuals by doing mri scans but
first of all like you might not get a
very good idea of how the
brain is representing those images
because there's a lot of noise in the
mri scan and there's a limit to how long
you can scan each person
whereas i guess in a neural network like
noise is not a problem the entire system
is deterministic we just pass in the
image and we get
the representation vector and you also
have these kinds of limits of
like we we can't see what happens if
people have bigger brains
like we can't manipulate the
architecture in those kinds of ways
so even though we can look at how intact
brains are working we can't see how
representations change when we
manipulate
them all that easily and i guess again
in machine learning like we can do all
of those things we can look at what
happens when we change the loss function
we can look at what happens when we make
the network deeper or wider
so i think there are like some really
cool ways that
even the same techniques can be applied
in machine learning
that they couldn't be applied in
neuroscience
i felt like we weren't getting very far
by trying to
record from neurons in monkeys brains
and figure out how those neurons work
like it didn't really seem like a very
effective way of
figuring out how the brain constructs
this kind of
internal representation of the world so
from there i thought about what could we
actually do to understand this
and it seemed like the most promising
thing to do was to look at
what happens in simpler systems that we
can construct
ourselves and where we can analyze the
behavior of everything inside the system
so in a neural network we can record all
the neurons which is extremely
challenging in a biological organism
and we can also manipulate the system in
any
kind of way that we can imagine but it
still seems like really hard to
understand neural networks
so it seemed like maybe this was a more
tractable challenge
and a challenge where maybe we could
make some headway that
might eventually translate back to
brains and so that's how i ended up in
machine learning
i guess there are like other great
things about machine learning i guess
the the pay is much better than in like
academic neuroscience
but really i think like it's a logical
progression based on the ideas that i
was interested in and i i
am still interested in the same sorts of
ideas
do you still think now that you're in
machine learning and have made some
progress here
that there is a good chance that we're
going to map
our knowledge that we gain back to the
brain
or do you think there is a bit of a
disconnect
i i think that's a really good question
i i think there's definitely some
knowledge
that we're going to get from machine
learning that will map back to the brain
i i think like in terms of general
principles and ways of
looking at how like information
processing systems work
i think there are a lot of ideas from
machine learning
that will ultimately help us understand
brains
i'm a little less sure whether we're
going to build
like a a machine learning system that is
a brain i think there's
a disconnect between the way that the
systems that we build work and the way
that biology works and i think that's
insurmountable just because
there's differences between what you can
build efficiently with cells and what
you can build efficiently
in silicon but in terms of
approaches to understanding in terms of
building tools to understand
things the tools that we build in
machine learning i
i think will eventually be useful in
neuroscience
so people make a lot of analogies
and they make a lot of claims about
neuroscience in connections
with neural networks is there a
statement or a bunch of statements that
you hear
over and over again where you just
cringe because they're
so wrong is that something that happens
to you
i can imagine it would yeah yeah so i
think there's this like kind of
basic fact that neural networks are
inspired by brains which is true
but then there's like all this other
stuff where people try to relate
whatever neural network they've built
back to a brain and they say that it
works like the brain but it doesn't work
like the
brain there's still like this huge kind
of disconnect in
how the system is actually operating the
brain is not
literally doing backprop it might be
doing something that's like
backprop we still don't really know but
it's not like literally computing
gradients
by automatic differentiation i'm
fascinated to talk about this line of
reasoning that you have because
you're clearly the kind of guy that you
want to reason about the behavior of
models and in particular the evolution
of representations and
i watched one of your presentations on
youtube where you were talking about how
you can compare
the representations by comparing
features and of course the naive way of
doing it is the dot product or some
variations of that
turns out that doesn't work very well
and you came up with this wonderful
metric called the
the centered kernel alignment so how did
that all come about
the way we came up with that idea was
that jeff hinton had another idea and i
tried the idea
that it worked but then we wondered is
there a simpler thing that worked
and that's how we ended up with centered
kernel alignment i guess
the problem that that we had in trying
to come up with a way of
comparing similarity of neural network
representations is that it's really hard
to know
what is a good way like it's not
something where you can really develop a
good benchmark
so like in the paper we came up with
this simple sanity check
where the idea is basically we've got
two
architecturally identical neural
networks and we just train them from
different random initializations and so
we want it to be the case that if you
measure like
the similarity between a layer from
network a and
all the layers from network b that the
most similar layer in network b
is going to be the architecturally
corresponding layer so if we have
layer 2 from network a it should be more
similar to
layer 2 from network b than layer 3 or
layer 4.
and so like basically we found that what
people had been doing before
didn't always pass that sanity check and
we basically tried to come up with the
simplest way of building
a similarity index that did actually
pass that sanity check
and that's how we ended up with centered
colonel alignment
yeah because i think you showed that the
the canonical correlation analysis only
worked about
i think had an accuracy of about 1.4
percent so it's complete apples and
oranges but
this absolutely fascinates me though
because when you plot this thing in this
kind of self-similarity
uh matrix you can glean so much about
the evolution
as a function of time and because you
talk about this in one of
one of the other papers as well that
there's this characteristic blockiness
and when you see blockiness that
successive layers
are similar to versions of themselves in
the past
and that kind of means that they're not
evolving anymore
and you then made the intuition in your
paper that was essentially it's
redundant information if it's not
learning anything new
i can just delete that block i can just
delete those layers from the neural
network and it won't make any difference
and indeed it didn't
yeah could you
for uh people listening explain the
similarity
measure you came up with in principle
just so we can imagine something
how that should even work yeah
so i guess the idea is like you've got a
neural network and you feed
some set of examples like multiple
examples through the neural network and
now you've got like some matrix where
the rows of the matrix
are like different examples and the
columns are
different neurons so yeah you can
imagine this as
if you have vectors of activations for
each example you've stacked them
real wise so now what do we do with that
to
compare two neural networks trained from
different random initializations
the problem is if we were to just take
the square difference between those
matrices we have this problem
that like the neurons between these two
different networks aren't necessarily
aligned in any way if they're trained
from different random initializations
even if we had exactly the same neurons
we shouldn't expect that
neuron one would be the same
representing the same thing in both
networks
so we need some way to get around that
problem one way around this problem
is instead of comparing the
these original matrices we're going to
make matrices that measure the
similarity
of each example to each other example
for one particular network so if we've
got
like example a and example b we can
measure their similarity
very simply just by taking the dot
product between those two vectors
and now because we're measuring
similarity from the same network we
don't have to worry about this alignment
problem and we get some idea of
how similar different examples are to
each other
according to the representation in
network a so if we do that for all the
examples we get some
examples by examples matrix and then we
can do that
both for our first network and for our
second network
so after we've done that we've got these
two examples by examples matrices
and then the easy way to compare those
matrices
is we just reshape them to vectors and
we take the dot product again
between those vectors so now we've
measured the similarities between the
similarities
of the examples and this doesn't have
this problem of
aligning the neurons because instead of
measuring similarities of neurons we're
measuring similarities of examples and
then we're comparing those similarities
so ultimately we do that we take that
dot product and then we
normalize it in a way that makes it
invariant to scaling so if you
just took the dot product you'd have
this problem uh that
scaling all of the features by some
number
if you scale everything by a factor of
two the dot product will go up by a
factor of two
and so we just apply some normalization
so that kind of scaling will not affect
the similarity index
and we get centered kernel alignment
which gives us a similarity
score between zero and one the the
fascinating thing is that you can
replace that dot product with a kernel
because it's a gram
matrix yeah so did you find that it made
a difference if you use let's say the
rbf kernel
yeah yeah so yeah basically when we're
measuring the similarities between
examples we can just
instead of taking the dot product
between the representations of the
different examples we can take the
kernel
between one example and another example
because the kernel is also
a way of measuring similarity and so we
tried
that it turns out that like for cnns it
didn't really make a difference like the
rbf kernel worked but so did just taking
a regular dot product
but we did find in in the appendix of
that
paper that if you instead use an rvf
kernel with a transformer it actually
does
work better than taking a normal dot
product and i think like part of what's
going on
is that sometimes you want it to be the
case that when you're measuring
similarity
you care more about the distances
between
the examples that you're close to than
the distances to the examples that
you're far away from
like once you're really far away from
something maybe it doesn't matter so
much if you're
ten times as far away because like
you're already so far
you're already not going to you you
don't really care
how far away something is once you're
far enough
and the rvf kernel takes that into
account in a way that a linear dot
product wouldn't the linear dot product
is like very sensitive
to the global distances in the space
what i find fascinating is that you can
glean so much from the blockiness right
so you were saying that as it becomes
blockier
it might be an indication that it's
become saturated in some sense
and i'm also interested in in a way we
already know that the
representations in neural networks are
increasingly abstract so they don't
necessarily bear any resemblance to the
beginning so when we're looking at the
cell similarity matrix we don't
necessarily want the
representations on the final penultimate
layers to be
similar to the ones at the beginning we
want there to be a continuous
evolution we don't want to have a
stalled evolution because that would
correspond to like this blockiness
but is it when you've stalled for a long
time is that when it becomes
pathological because we want it to
evolve
in stops and starts don't we yeah i i
think it's not clear what we should
really expect in terms of how
a neural network representation evolves
through the layers
i think there's kind of some theory on
what we should expect if all the layers
are linear
but like obviously the neural networks
that we train are non-linear and
it's really important to have a
non-linearity in between the layers
and so at that point it's like really
hard to reason about
what the optimal thing for a neural
network to do
actually is i think it's something that
we could really only study empirically
on the other hand i do think if we see
that nothing is changing from one layer
to
the next that's a really bad sign if the
neural network representation isn't
changing then obviously nothing's
happening
but i guess it's unclear whether we
should expect like
abrupt shifts or we want things to
happen slowly between the layers
i'm not sure whether we really have the
theoretical knowledge to
to say what is best yeah i'd love to see
this
as a kind of tool in our toolbox that we
could use on different network
architectures but
you you said that the other learned
features are shared across different
initializations and architectures
particularly across the depths of the
network so it almost seems as if
this blockiness is separate to your work
in
wide and deep neural networks because
you showed that the width and the depth
have got different effects on network
predictions
at the example level or at the class
level but the blockiness almost seems to
be an orthogonal thing that's just
when you have this kind of saturation of
the network you see the blockiness
yeah yeah so initially we had hoped that
we could look at other
similarities between wide networks and
deep networks
in their representations but like when
we did those experiments we actually
just found that
if you make the network really wide you
get this kind of blockiness in the
representations and those blocks are
like dissimilar across different
initializations
and then the same thing happens if you
make the network really deep we see
these like big
blocks in the representations so that
made it hard to
study these very wide and very deep
networks from
the representational similarity
perspective but at the same time i think
it's like a really interesting
observation
like it's something where we we couldn't
have predicted this ahead of time
based on what we know about neural
network theory and we couldn't have
predicted it ahead of time
based on the accuracy of the network
it's something where we really needed
like these these techniques for looking
at the internal representations of
neural networks
to see what was happening inside of them
there's this
you know whole literature that takes a
look at a network's expressibility with
regards to its depth
and width so could you just explain it
to us whether or not we should be able
to meaningfully quantify or
formulate the expressibility of a neural
network with regards to your analysis
made on that page yeah so there's this
work that looks at
like kind of the the functions that can
be expressed by wide networks and the
functions that can be expressed by deep
networks and i guess
like the neural networks seem to become
exponentially more expressive as you
make them deeper
so it seems like in that sense depth is
more important than with but on the
other hand
like the neural networks that we
actually train in this paper
like both the wide networks and the deep
networks are big enough that they can
overfit the entire
training set so in this case like the
expressibility of the network is not
really important what's important is the
function that the network actually ends
up learning so i guess even though
networks could express more functions
when they're deep
what we're really studying is the
function that you actually get when you
train the
neural network by gradient descent on
some data what the optimization process
actually
finds one thing as well in that paper
you
talked about the network pathology right
and you said that two times depth
accuracy 95 percent four times 93.2
eight times 91.9 so because this is this
runs counter to what a lot of us would
intuit we think that
you can have as much depth as you want
and architectures like resnet in some
sense they learn their own capacity
there is a pathology there happening
clearly and how would you
determine that from this visualization
yeah
so i guess there are two kind of results
so like
you you can either look at networks
without residual connections where you
do actually find that at some depth
the accuracy will start going down and
and in in networks without residual
connections we find that like
that the depth where accuracy starts to
go down is like around the same depth
where you begin seeing this kind of
block structure where
many successive layers have similar
representations and it looks like the
representation is no longer getting
refined through the network
yeah i mean with resnets you can make
them much deeper
and it seems like it doesn't hurt
accuracy as much even once you start
getting these blocks
but it also seems once you start getting
these blocks making the network deeper
making that work wider no longer really
gives you
any improvement in accuracy so it seems
like this is basically telling you that
the network has
fit the data as much as it can and and
there's no
real advantage to using something bigger
fascinating let's move on to another
paper that you've done which is
quite related in terms of you've used
the same analysis to reason about it but
you had a paper called what's in a loss
function for image classification
and you looked at a whole bunch of
different labels moving and regularizers
which are things that you do on the end
of the network and you identify
differences
in accuracy and calibration and
out-of-domain distribution
and you made some really interesting
observations so by the way we're talking
about things like do we use the softmax
or the squared error or dropout or label
smoothing or
logic penalty but you noticed using the
same analysis technique that only
affected the representations on the
penultimate
layers of the neural network what's
going on there
yeah so it's not just the penultimate
layer it's like the
the last maybe third of the network is
affected by the loss function but then
the first two thirds of the network it
seems like you learn the same
representation
no matter what loss function you use so
it doesn't change if you use label
smoothing
it doesn't even change if you use mean
squared error instead of using
softmax cross entropy you still
basically learn the same representation
for the
the first two thirds of the network and
i think it's still it's a bit of a
puzzle to us
why this happens clearly it matters that
you're training the network with the
loss function
those those layers in the first two
thirds of the network do
change from the initialization but i
guess it seems that the last
third of the network is setting up the
penultimate layer representation
in a way that is good for your loss
function but
the first two thirds of the network are
are somehow just learning
general features i think this also like
corresponds with the
success of transfer learning where we
can take features that we've learned on
one task and transfer them to some other
task
what's the implication though it seems
is the implication that the loss
function is not having any impact
on the representations early on in the
network that seems like quite a big
implication
yeah i i think like the loss function
must have some
impact because if you don't if you don't
train the network if you don't have any
loss function at all
then like the the representation
in that first two thirds of the network
is actually
quite different i think what's really
happening is there are these differences
among the loss functions which don't
really matter
except later in the network although
they will give you like a slight change
in accuracy
and like slight changes in robustness
they don't matter for this general
feature learning process
i guess like it maybe it's what we
should expect because
ultimately we're asking the network to
do the same thing just in a slightly
different way we're still asking the
network to classify images
we're just asking it to provide slightly
different outputs to produce a slightly
different
representation at the penultimate layer
so maybe we should expect that
like those early features or earlier
features
that are just trying to represent
general things about images
like those will be the same no matter
what loss function we pick
yeah in your experiments did you find
whether or not model capacity has
anything to do with it
yeah so we didn't really investigate
different model capacities in that paper
i i would expect that the same
thing holds for a wide range of model
capacities i guess there's no indication
from the experiments that if you use a
bigger network or
a slightly smaller network that things
would change all that much
but yeah i think it's still an open
question how model capacity
changes things i guess in in the
simclear paper we found that model
capacity can matter quite a bit
yeah so the general hypothesis there
should also hold
even though your model is bigger or
smaller no matter how
big or smaller your network is the
general feature learning regime or
paradigm should still
hold no matter what loss function you
would end up use
using yeah that would be my guess i
think if you're in a regime where it's
really hard for you to fit the training
data
if you have a very small network it
might be the case that you see
more differences in the earlier layers
because it might be
that like the loss function really
affects
what features are best there in a way
that it wouldn't if the network is a bit
bigger and if it's
more capable of fitting your training
data
but i don't really know like i think
this is something that that is probably
worth looking at in some follow-up work
and you found also there's implications
for for transfer learning
with respect to the loss function there
seems to be like some inverse
correlation between the gains you get
from a loss function
and how good it is for transfer learning
or
is it is there like a connection between
loss functions and regularizers and all
of that
yeah we look at just linear transfer in
the paper so if we take
the features from the penultimate layer
and we try to use them directly for some
other task
how good are those features going to be
and what we found was
that if you use lost functions that
give you higher accuracy on imagenet you
tend to learn
representations that transfer
substantially worse
in that setting and our intuition is
you could learn many different kinds of
representations in that penultimate
layer and still do a reasonable job of
classifying imagenet
but what seems to happen is that
the loss functions that perform better
lead classes to become
more separated in the penultimate layer
so like class a and class b
will be farther apart relative to the
variability within the class
and when you have a situation like that
you have this
penultimate layer representation that's
specialized for the classes in imagenet
like you
you've got a thousand clusters
corresponding to the thousand classes in
imagenet
and so then if you want to use like
those kinds of representations for some
other tasks
it will only really work well if you
have exactly the same classes that are
in imagenet because they're already
organized by the imagenet classes
on the other hand what we found is if
you just use standard softmax loss
actually the classes are not that
separated from each other in the
penultimate layer representation
and because they're not that separated
there are these features that you could
use
to classify things that are not imagenet
that still
convey some kind of useful information
about the images that are not
just their imagenet class labels
it hints at a bit of a future where you
know like right now on
whatever tensorflow hub or hogging face
repositories and so on
we have these pre-trained models and the
pre-trend models
they're like full stack models and
people usually take some sort of
last or next to last hidden layer
but maybe we should much more focus on
actually providing like half of a
network to share
like determining which are actually the
best good
or general representations from a data
set and so on
do you have any of this in mind when you
do work like this
yeah at google what is generally best
for us to do is just to fine-tune the
whole network
and if you fine-tune the whole network
it eliminates some of these issues with
the actual form of the representation in
the penultimate layer
because even if you have this kind of
highly specialized penultimate layer
when if you're allowed to change all the
other weights in the network you can fix
that and you can specialize the rest of
the network
for some other task but yeah i think
like it's a really interesting question
if we just want to turn an image into a
vector that we could then train a linear
classifier on top of
what is the best way of doing that how
should we approach that problem and how
should we approach that problem if we
want
this very like general universal vector
representation of an image that would
work well for a lot of different
tasks and i think we don't really have
good ways of doing that because
basically this is all empirical right
like we don't know
what makes a good universal
representation of an image we've just
got to try a bunch of things
and figure out what works best and i
guess yeah the insight from this paper
is like actually the loss
function that you use to train the
network can make a huge difference there
fascinating i guess without any further
ado we should
move on to simclear a simple framework
for contrastive learning of visual
representations
we've been absolutely fascinated by this
concept of unsupervised contrastive
image representation learning algorithms
we've seen such a huge kind of step
forward haven't we over the last couple
of years in this area
yeah it's pretty amazing to me
could you just go back to real basics
imagine that people out there have been
living in a cave they don't know what
contrast of learning is they don't know
about
image augmentation how would you frame
the whole thing up
the self-supervised learning setup is
we've got a a bunch of
images and at least the initial
like historical self-supervised learning
setup is we've got a bunch of images
we want to train some kind of neural
network on it
and we want that neural network to learn
a representation such that
when we then just train a linear
classifier on top of that representation
to classify imagenet it's going to do
well but we want to learn the initial
representation without
using any kind of labels and
yeah i guess there are a lot of
different approaches that people tried
for this problem like people tried
things like
let's train a neural network so that we
can cut up the image
into uh just a grid and shuffle the grid
and then the neural network has to
figure out how to assemble these puzzle
pieces back into the original image
and maybe that'll give us a good
representation or let's try
just rotating the images so we can have
images that are rotated 90 180 270
degrees
and then we'll have the neural network
try to classify what rotation
we fed into it and so people came up
with these
kinds of tasks that you could try to
train a neural network to do
so that it would learn some kind of good
representation they were defined in this
ad hoc way let's come up with some kind
of funny thing
where you don't need a label you can
have the neural network
trained to do this kind of thing and
maybe it'll learn something about
images starting in around 2018
there are a few papers that basically
suggested this
alternative approach where you're trying
to
learn some kind of representation space
where you've got
different patches from an image or
different augmentations from an image
just different representations of the
same image
and you want to learn a representation
space where these representations of the
same image
are all close together in that
representation space
and they're far apart from the
representations of other images
this surprisingly seems to lead to very
good representations
but there it turns out there are a lot
of very important details to get this to
work well
so it's really like a situation where
the basic idea is very simple let's
create multiple views
of an image and try to get them close to
each other and far away from everything
else
but things like augmentation and and
things like the exact way we set up the
network
end up being very important to learning
a good representation with this kind of
technique
how does the negative sampling work
people have done this in different ways
so in simclear
our way of doing negative sampling is
very simple so like
basically we we are attracting
two views of the the same image and then
we have a mini batch that has 4096
images in it and two augmentations of
each image
and so we are repelling using a softmax
from all of the other
8190 views in that mini batch
basically we want our
two augmentations of the same image
close and we want them to be
far from the other 8190 images
it's a yeah it's a bit of a throwback to
to
word to vac i i think it's pretty cool
how these ideas just come up
through the through the eras and and
through the different models and so on
and there is
seemingly always another layer on top of
these ideas pretty cool
yeah so if you
only consider you know two views that
are coming out of the same image as the
positive pair so to speak and all the
other
views are coming out of the different
images located in the same mini batch
wouldn't this
hurt the representation space to some
extent
let's say you have multiple images of
dogs
in a mini batch of 4096 samples
we would essentially want the
representations of different dogs to map
together
as closer as possible in the
presentation space while
representations of cats from dogs would
get further away wouldn't we expect this
but how does simclear ensure this
rigorously
i guess it's because of the larger batch
sizes you use but i still wanted to
know from you yeah one thing is even if
we've got other kinds of images that we
want to be close together in the mini
batch
even if we've got like a dog image and
then another dog image and
ultimately we want to learn a
representation space where maybe they're
not so far apart
like on average most of the images
in the mini batch are things that we
want to be really far apart from
so maybe it doesn't hurt that much if
we're repelling from
everything as opposed to just repelling
from
images that are part of other classes i
i think this actually is something that
hurts
current self-supervised learning
techniques and hurts contrastive
techniques because we also know
when you do the contrastive loss if you
don't contrast against
examples that are very close to you that
actually improves things a little bit
so if you don't contrast against the
very hard negatives
we've found that gives you slightly
higher accuracy when you do this linear
evaluation
that kind of suggests that this really
is a problem with these techniques that
maybe sometimes you don't want to be as
far apart from other images as the
losses encouraging you to be
now there's one other aspect which is
that in simclear
we don't actually use the representation
that's feeding into the loss function
like we have this projection head an mlp
on top of the network and instead of
using that representation at the end of
the network we use
a representation that's two layers back
and so by using a representation that's
two layers
back even if in the final layer we're
pushing things apart we kind of figure
that
this earlier representation might not
have pushed apart the things that really
are semantically similar
and indeed we find that like using this
earlier representation in the network
leads to higher linear evaluation
accuracy so it works better
i was very fascinated by all of these
different tricks that you
apparently have to get and so big kudos
to you know
figuring all of this out for the rest of
us there has been
there's been a lot of follow-up work on
this idea
there's very like a lot of modifications
there's this bootstrap your own latent
where
they completely leave out the negative
sampling then
i think just like one or two weeks ago
there's there was a paper saying
if you build in a stop gradient
into the contrastive loss
you also apparently don't need a
negative and so on
do you have maybe from your own work or
from work of others do you have any
sort of current if i were to build a
a self-supervised contrastive
representation
learner today what is the top things i
should do what is my recipe
how do i go about it the most important
part of the recipe
is data augmentation so like we're going
to use two views from the same image
and it's very important how those two
views are constructed
but they're really only two super
important
data augmentations that we need so we
have to take
two different crops from the same image
and then we have to do some kind of
color distortion
so in sinclair we use like very
aggressive color distortion
so that is probably the most important
part of the recipe
then i guess we feed that representation
into a neural network
and fortunately we found that you can
just use
a regular resnet50 for this part you
don't have to worry about
architecture engineering specifically
for contrastive learning
then i think all of the work since
simclear also uses this idea of putting
an mlp
on top of the end of the network and
then using that
uh to get whatever representation goes
into the loss function
but then discarding part of the mlp when
we
later just want the representation for a
downstream task
all of those pieces are pieces
that are shared by all of these modern
uh self-supervised learning techniques
so like we introduce uh the idea of this
projection head in simclear
and we also spend a lot of time studying
the augmentation although
we were not the first people to come up
with the idea that the augmentation was
important
yeah in terms of what the loss function
is i guess it's surprising that
there are so many things that work that
we use this contrastive loss in sim
clear because it was what previous work
had done
and it's like intuitive that you might
want to learn a space
where you're explicitly pushing away
representations of other examples
but i guess like in byol they aren't
explicitly contrasting against
representations of other examples so
instead they have a network where
they're taking a moving average of of
the weights
that they've been learning and they try
to match the representation that's
coming out of the network that they're
training
to this representation of this moving
average network
and somehow magically that works and
i guess it doesn't even have to be a
moving average i i think you were
referring to earlier
like you you can just match the
representation of one network
to stop gradient of the same network as
long as you're matching the
representation in an earlier layer
and i think like it's still like
mysterious
why that should work i don't really have
any insight
into how either vyol
or the more recent papers
actually are learning a representation
that doesn't end up collapsing
the problem is if you're trying to match
some earlier representation
you you could just collapse to the point
where all of your representations are
the same and then
like you would trivially be matching the
earlier representation
but this doesn't happen and i think
why it doesn't happen relates to some
mysteries about neural network training
dynamics
that we still don't entirely understand
i'm absolutely fascinated by this
concept of data
augmentation early on in my neural
network career i just imagined it as
being a way of increasing the size of
your
training set but in a sense you're not
really adding new information
it's you are creating semantically
equivalent
noise perturbations or examples similar
to how bert works the nlp model
it's like a de-noising auto encoder and
you're creating noise versions of the
same thing and pushing the examples off
the manifold
so there seems to be a dichotomy between
on the one hand augmenting your data and
it's almost like you're stopping the
neural network from overfitting
on things like the the color or some
specific feature you don't want to you
want to have a bit of generalization but
at the same
time you you are saying those things
over there it's definitely nothing like
that
the data augmentation that you need for
contrastive learning is different from
supervised learning because the task is
different
when you have contrastive learning you
have this problem that
if there's just one feature in your data
that can be used
to do the contrastive task to get images
of the same example or views of the same
example close together and far apart
from views of all the other examples if
you could do that with one feature
that would be the only feature the
network would ever learn or it might be
the only feature the network would ever
learn
and so with the augmentation you're
making the task harder so that the
network actually has to learn
many different kinds of features so i
guess we find that like
this color distortion actually is very
important for
self-supervised learning for contrastive
learning whereas it doesn't really
matter for supervised learning
and what we think is going on is that if
you have two crops from the same image
like generally their color histograms
are surprisingly similar if you just
plot out the
intensity histogram of the image you can
see that the
crops came from the same image and
that's a trick
that the network is very good at doing
because i guess if you have
relu activations they're very good at
computing histograms
and so by doing the color distortion we
basically
we we don't let the network just learn
the color histograms in order to do the
contrastive task we force the network
to actually use other sorts of
information and that ends up being like
critical to the performance of these
contrasted methods like it basically
doesn't work unless you do
that kind of aggressive color distortion
because that seems to be the key thing
then so you're not
telling it to learn things you're
telling it not to learn things
we're telling it to learn one thing
we're telling it to learn
figure out which views came from the
same image but then
yeah we have to make sure that it learns
to do that with
a diverse set of features instead of
just doing it in one way
because i guess it's like a task that's
actually pretty easy to do
if you don't have this kind of
aggressive augmentation
yeah i think in a way it helps the
network to
also differentiate what actually what is
the thing that differentiates two images
i think it helps the network to learn
you know pick up on that signal to that
end i also wanted to ask
for a custom data set if i wanted to you
know apply
uh sinclair what pointers should i take
into consideration while
designing my augmentation policy i'm
sure you have been asked about this
question quite a few times but yeah
i think it's a good question like i
think like we actually still don't
really know how generalizable these
contrastive learning techniques are
beyond imagenet like we know
they work super well on imagenet but
like imagenet is like a boring data set
to apply contrastive learning
to because we actually already have all
the labels and we could just be doing
supervised learning
but i i think starting with the crop
and color augmentation is definitely a
good idea at least like for
data sets that have color i guess if you
don't have color then
maybe think about distorting intensities
instead of
colors but beyond that i think it
depends on the specific task and what
you really want the neural network to
pick out
up out of the data set i feel like there
are probably
some sorts of data where i wouldn't
really expect
contrastive learning to work well so for
example
like if you try to do contrastive
learning on a data set
of medical images where you've just got
healthy patients and then you want to
translate that to
like some sort of data set of people
with some kind of pathology you might
never
pick up the features that are important
for detecting the pathology
but yeah i think this question of how do
you design the augmentation what
augmentation works well for data sets
that maybe aren't natural images
like these kinds of medical images or
maybe like satellite images
that's an important question that we
haven't addressed yet there seems to be
this fascinating universality of
representations especially in vision
this is exactly the kind of thing you
can test with your
wonderful similarity matrix um idea
i'm not trying to be flippant when i say
this because practitioners have used
imagenet on a variety of downstream
tasks for example they might use it for
classifying circuit boards or something
and the miraculous thing is it just
seems to work quite well so
do you think in your opinion that there
is some kind of universality
i'm very skeptical about like
universality of imagenet for different
tasks
like in the past we we did some work
where we looked at how
well imagenet networks transfer to other
tasks
and it seems like they're actually some
which are just like data sets of natural
images
where pre-training on imagenet doesn't
really help at all
and those data sets just seem to be too
different from imagenet they're things
like
this stanford cars data set where you
have to
like classify different cars according
to their make model and year
it turns out even though there are lots
of cars in imagenet if you free trade on
imagenet and you fine tune on that data
set
you will learn to classify it faster in
fewer steps than if you had trained
from scratch on the the stanford cars
data set
but you won't actually perform any
better at the end and that's true even
though the
the stanford cars data set has 10 000
images so it's tiny compared to
imagenet so i think like actually
representations of images
are not that universal and at least what
works
for natural images for images like those
in imagenet
may not work on other data sets i think
there's
also like limited evidence for transfer
from
imagenet to medical data sets it seems
if you don't
like work really hard at tuning hyper
parameters or if you don't train for
long enough
you will get better accuracy by starting
with an imagenet pre-trained network but
if
you do very thorough experiments and you
train for long enough you try different
learning rates and weight decay
parameters
like actually it seems like training
from scratch on most medical data sets
will give you the same accuracy as if
you started from a network that's
pre-trained on some other giant data set
maybe this makes sense because if you
think about radiologists like it's not
like
a radiologist can just like at the
beginning of their education they can't
just look at
an mri or an x-ray image and say this is
where the tumor is
it's something that takes them years of
training to learn how to do
and so maybe it also makes sense that
like our neural networks
can't just immediately easily without
lots of training
pick up on uh very different image
distributions
it does seem to make sense going a bit
from the
universality of representations
to the universality of augmentation
since this is such a crucial part do you
think that there is
a systematic way how we can discover
augmentations because it seems right now
it seems to be kind of a whack-a-mole
right it's okay we just feed images
since no that's too easy we cropped them
oh no it's the color histogram so we
like whack on the color and then
it works better but maybe someone finds
out oh there is still this easy feature
that the network
every every now and then pays attention
to so we
design a method to whack on that a bit
do you think there's a
systematic way or will this kind of
philosophically always rely on us humans
having a higher level insight of what we
want to do
with the data set yeah so i i think
actually i'm hopeful that at least for
natural images
just like crops and color distortions
are enough
because i guess like what we found is
you combine those two augmentations and
if you do that
like that gets you most of the way to
supervised accuracy
so maybe we shouldn't expect huge gains
from adding additional augmentations on
top of that
even though they're like in the sim
clear paper we add
like gaussian blur which gives slight
gains on top of that i guess in the b by
l paper
they add even more augmentations on top
of that so you can get small gains
but it seems like the gains are much
smaller once you've
got the crops and the color distortions
there
in terms of systematic ways of
discovering
what set of augmentations we should be
using
i guess there's a paper that i saw where
they basically
use linear evaluation on the rotation
prediction
task to see whether the augmentations
are good and they claim that actually
works for evaluating the augmentations
so maybe
that's one way i don't know there are
all sorts of ways of designing
augmentations for supervised learning
that could
conceivably be applied to the
self-supervised learning
setting to the contrastive setting like
there are these
meta learning based approaches for
learning data augmentation
i'm not sure like those techniques tend
to be pretty complicated
i'm not sure whether it's actually
easier to deal with those techniques
than just like trying a bunch of things
but i i think that maybe it doesn't
matter that much
maybe like just at least if you're
dealing with natural images
maybe uh crop and color distortion is
enough
i guess if you think about other images
i don't really have any idea i i guess
it depends on what the images look like
there are lots of things that you could
be expressing as images
like a spectrogram or like a some kind
of chart or whatever
where you could be applying a neural
network to it but like the further you
get from natural images the less clear
it is
what kind of augmentations you should be
working with
it is a fascinating thought though this
universality of augmentations and
when you said cropping and and color
that made me think it seems to be
related to the inductive priors in
in the cnn architecture that we use and
also to things like
it's regularly sampled gridded discrete
image data
because we're speaking with max welling
the other week and as he's created lots
of other interesting inductive priors
for
computer vision models but it does set
my mind racing a little bit because
presumably there's a continuum so
on the one hand we don't do any
augmentation and we just learn from
examples
in the middle we do the augmentation and
then maybe in the future because some
people have said that computer vision
systems don't have seen understanding
they don't understand physics
the ball might be on the table but we
don't know that it's not falling and so
on
there's a lot of missing information so
would the next step be some simulation
do you know what i mean where we impute
physics and we impute some world
knowledge and then i don't know whether
we train a machine learning model from
that
yeah i think like there are definitely
shortcomings in
like our current machine learning models
understandings of the world
they're they're probably things that we
can't just solve by throwing more static
images at them
i think like maybe the next step rather
than trying to
immediately situate the machine learning
model in a kind of a simulated world we
could just think about
video i think there's already like a lot
of additional information in video that
a neural network could use
to learn like interesting
representations
i guess like it seems like if you just
see static images it's hard to learn
how to segment objects it's hard to
learn like where the objects boundaries
are but once you have video it's like
the stuff that's moving together is an
object and you can tell that because
it's moving together
so i think there's a lot of potential
for learning better visual
representations
from video and and maybe eventually from
like these kinds of interactions
in simulated environments but i think
like ultimately it becomes
a computational headache like even video
is a computational headache because
suddenly you've got all these frames
that you have to deal with you probably
want to be
thinking about how representations
change over time and
video data is just huge and it's
especially huge if you have to
process many frames at once on your
accelerators
so i think that's like why this hasn't
taken off
yet but i think like probably
representation learning from video is
gonna be
like a big thing next year or like the
year after
something sometime in the near future we
would love to talk about your big
self-supervised models are strong
semi-supervised learners so this is
super interesting right because you're
combining
the unsupervised stuff that we've been
talking about in simchat but now we're
in the semi-supervised domain where the
the kind of label efficiency becomes
super important so what's the deal there
yeah so i guess in simclear we focus on
this question of
linear evaluation accuracy where we're
just learning a representation
without any labels and then training a
linear classifier on top of that
representation
on the same data but now with all the
labels it turns out that's not really a
very practical
problem if you have all the labels
there's not necessarily any
reason in practice that you would want
to first
learn this representation and then train
the classifier versus just doing
standard supervised end-to-end training
but what is a practical problem is the
situation where you have
a lot of unlabeled data and then a very
small amount of labeled data
and so that's the the situation that we
look at
in simclear v2 in in that paper
and what we find there is that you can
train
this network fully unsupervised without
using the labels on all the data
and then you can fine-tune it on just
the subset where you've got the labels
and if you do that it's possible to get
very
high accuracy especially if the network
is very big
so basically we find if you have a
really big resnet if you have resnet 152
and then you make the layers three times
wider when you do that you can get
accuracy
when you fine tune on 10 of the labels
that's like
substantially better than if you trained
resnet 50 from scratch with all the
labels
and once you have that really big
network it turns out
you don't have to put the really big
network into production you can take the
really big network
and you can then distill it back into a
standard resnet 50
and you can retain almost all of the
accuracy when you do that
but i guess what's important about this
distillation process is we're not just
going to distill
on the labeled dataset we're going to
also use
the labels that this
giant network which we fine-tuned on a
small subset of the data
we're going to use the labels that it
gives on
all of our unlabeled data so we're going
to use it to generate labels and then
we're just going to use those labels
to train a much smaller network and if
we do that we get accuracy
that's similar to or maybe even slightly
better than standard supervised
training from scratch this becomes a
highly
practically relatable approach toward
doing computer vision related things we
see all the times that folks have a huge
corpus of unlabeled
images but they only have maybe five
percent or
ten percent playback images so this
immediately becomes a practically
applicable recipe for them so i
definitely
i'm looking forward to seeing this thing
implemented
at scale at different companies so
that's there and if i understood it
correctly just for the viewers
you folks used a variant of uh
distillation here which is more
popularly referred to as self training
yeah i don't think there's really a
difference between
what we call distillation and what other
people call self-training
but yeah i guess the idea is basically
we will
pass information into the network we get
its
output probabilities and then we train
another neural network
with those output probabilities as the
targets
what i find fascinating is how many
ideas come
together in this paper so there's first
there's this let's do representation
learning
and then we have these just small labels
right we fine tune
and then there's big networks small
networks and then
you also you label but you also apply
some noise if i understand correctly
in the process of transferring maybe i'm
misremembering that but there's a lot of
ideas that come together
yannick you probably confused it with
noisy student training
maybe use impose noise during the
student training
sorry maybe not but there's there is a
lot of ideas that come together and
something tells me that there was a
process
behind going you probably didn't sit
down
after a sinclair one and be like all
right what do we do for sim card two
okay let's do this so there it tells me
there was this process
could you if you can maybe elaborate a
bit on how did you
going to build up the system towards the
the final output was there like dead
ends or was it like
let's build up until we can no longer
make it better
how was that yeah so i i guess like
there was a bit of a process so after
after like the original simclear paper i
guess like it's clear from the simclear
paper that when we have
this bigger network we get much higher
linear evaluation accuracy than we do if
we just
train simclear with a resnet 50.
so then the question was like is there
some way that we can somehow eliminate
this
dependence on this giant network because
the giant network is annoying to work
with it's computationally expensive
it's big and so we first tried
what happens if you distill the
unsupervised
network we basically have this task that
is set up as
a form of cross-entropy loss when we're
doing the
contrastive learning and so you can also
think about distilling
on that task where you have some set of
you have a probability distribution that
corresponds to the similarity between an
image
and all the other images and you could
use those kinds of targets to distill
so we tried that and that kind of worked
but then we we also tried the approach
of first fine-tuning the big network and
then distilling it and it turned out
that worked
a lot better and so i guess
that was i guess we jumped straight to
distillation
because we knew that we could get much
better results
by using a giant network with simclear
and then
once you realize that distillation is
going to be important
like the only thing you've got to figure
out is what kind of distillation
should you be doing and what we found
was like this approach of
pre-training then fine-tuning then
distilling works a lot better than
pre-training than distilling
then fine-tuning how far
down do you think one can go with this
final
distillation step is this something that
is
conceivably going to be available on
let's say edge devices
at some point like that our glasses or
something
run with similar accuracies to these
giant
networks or is it more a factor of four
factor of 10
kind of stuff i think like there are
clearly some limits to distillation
like i guess like we probably shouldn't
expect
distillation of the the kind that we do
in sinclair v2 to work substantially
better than
like supervised distillation which has
been around for
quite a while now i i think what's
impressive is that
in the self-supervised case in the
contrastive case
like distillation basically allows you
to recover the same accuracy that you
would get from training supervised from
scratch whereas without it
like the accuracy is a lot worse so it
seems like it
it maybe matters more in this
contrastive case
but i i think like generally when you do
distillation
in the supervised case you can get like
maybe a percentage point gain
maybe a couple of percentage points and
i think that's probably about the limit
in terms of
the improvement that you could get from
any kind of distillation
based approach over supervised training
from scratch
fascinating that i don't know if you
know that we've been playing with gpt3
and you said something quite interesting
just now you said that they're
deterministic but
in gbt3 that's not really the case if
you sample from it deterministically it
gets stuck in cycles
so you you have to um do some kind of
trickery some kind of random sampling
from this distribution
and it might be the case in future
computer vision models
as well that we have to randomly sample
from them in some way because otherwise
it would get into some pathological
behavior
and it may be to do that we need to have
some kind of controller on the top so i
suppose my question is in the future
maybe
we will be in the stochastic regime and
what do you think about that
well gpd3 you're trying to generate data
so i guess when you generate data there
has to be some kind of noise that's
coming from somewhere
like the process of generating data is
like turning noise into data
but i guess for image classification we
we have the data and we just want to
turn it into a label
and so maybe there's like this implicit
notion of stochasticity and that
like the network gives some kind of
output distribution
but i think we still want everything to
be deterministic
if it can be deterministic like we
basically want the network to say
this is a dog with probability x
if there's some way to improve it with
stochasticity i don't know
i guess dropout used to be very popular
but it seems like it's not so popular
anymore and it doesn't really help us
very much with vision models
and also like even dropout is generally
only used when we train the neural
networks
on the other hand like the brain is very
stochastic
like the brain has lots of noise like
yeah i guess that kind of suggests that
maybe there's some way to leverage noise
to learn better representations in
neural networks as well and we just
don't quite
know the right way yet that's right max
welling said to us that he thinks that
the future of ai will have a generative
component he thinks that we
we have the matrix in our minds don't we
we have these simulations going on
all the time and we're generating new
scenarios
and it's related to the data
augmentation thing as well some people
have said to me in the past that using a
gan
might be a way of doing data
augmentation
and presumably that would require some
kind of stochastic sampling as well so
i suppose it's just quite interesting to
see where these two things might meet in
the middle at some point
yeah i don't know i guess like with
again using a gante to do data
augmentation you have this problem that
you still don't actually have more data
like you have a gan that's trained on
the same data
and so it might help you because like
your way of encoding inductive bias into
the gan
is different from your way of encoding
adaptive bias into the neural network
and maybe
like by having more inductive bias you
can learn a better function
but it's not you still don't have more
data and it seems like
without having more data like there's no
reason to expect a priority that you
will be able
to learn a better function i'm so glad
you said that was always my intuition
the amount of people that have said to
me that you should use again for data
augmentation
anyway what's the first thing you think
about
if you're like oh what could i use again
for and then you learn about data and
then
you're like wait this is so much more
date
yeah but it conceptually yes you don't
have you don't have more data and
ironically when you do the simple data
augmentations
you do have more data because you have
you put all the knowledge in there
as a human of what makes two images
dissimilar visually but
still equivalent semantically which
again is exactly the opposite it gives
you images that are
visually similar but it has no
intuition of what the semantic
similarity is
for my last question i actually want to
switch topics just a little bit to what
tim said at the beginning
namely your love of julia and so i have
seen a
number of especially data scientists be
strong advocates for for julia as a
language and so on do you do you want to
give
anyone sort of the pitch why should we
even
consider this yeah so i think like
julia is a much better programming
language than python in many ways
i guess one one thing and i guess the
thing that first attracted me to julia
is that it's really fast
like you can write julia code and like
with very little work
you will end up running as fast as
equivalent c
code so that's something that you can't
get out of standard python code if
you're just
writing a for loop in python it's going
to be super slow but in julia you don't
have to worry about all of that and you
don't have to worry about like saitan or
number all of this other stuff that
people have hacked on top of python
like julia is just designed to be fast
and it works
i think there are like other advantages
to
like julia as a language beyond that i
guess
it's built on this idea of generic
functions where you have a function
that can take multiple types and you can
define the function differently for the
different types
and this is something that we do all the
time when we're doing like machine
learning like we have matrix
multiplication which is
a different form of multiplication that
takes matrices and produces something
and i guess like in python
it it's so it used to be that you had to
type dot dot to me
to to multiply things but now it's like
they they have this ad symbol that does
matrix multiplication but julius
designed for these situations where
maybe beyond just matrices you have
these funny types of structured matrices
you have sparse matrices and you can
define special methods for the product
of a sparse matrix and a vector or
all sorts of things where you might want
different methods depending on the types
and
even though it seems like this is
complicated and you might have some
trouble picking
which version of the function is going
to be called at runtime
because julia is ultimately compiling
everything when you call it
and because it has this kind of strong
type
system it can ultimately pick which
method is
going to be used and compile that method
call in and you don't have to worry
about
picking which one and so it still ends
up being fast
i also think like there's this question
of
whether like the object-oriented python
or the object-oriented paradigm in
python
is really like the best paradigm for
machine learning because i guess like
it's like we have data
and then we have functions that operate
on the data but in the object-oriented
paradigm you want the functions that
operate on the data to be attached to
the data which is like a a weird way of
setting things up
and that julia is not set up that way
you have these data structures
and then because you are able to create
functions that specialize on the data
structures
you don't have to worry about attaching
those functions to the data structures
themselves
amazing dr simon cornblet thank you very
much for joining us this evening it's
been an absolute pleasure
thanks for having me thank you i really
hope you've enjoyed the show today we've
had so much fun making it
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments every
single one of them and we'll see you
back
next week